I can't be queen of auradon being king
must be hard been but losing dirt queen
must be even harder sure you were
totally loved up with Mal at the end of
descendants three but there were plenty
of challenges ahead and we're not
convinced your relationship was solid
enough to get through taking down the
barrier to the Isle was always going to
be tricky you'll have had both
Maleficent and the 80s on your case
would Maus VK roots have pulled her
towards an old flame or would you have
gravitated towards someone else one
thing's for sure the fallout from your
breakup would have been epic but we are
in this together
oh we're not well no we're speculating
that Malin Ben would have broken up
after d3 keep watching to the end to
discover the disastrous consequences
that could affect all the word on and
the isle if the power couple does indeed
call it quits reasons for the break-up
Malin Ben have had their fair share of
issues since they got together so it's a
definite possibility that they wouldn't
have lasted all the way to the altar
after the end of d3 we see three main
possibilities for this pair parting ways
don't you love me
reason one the pressure of ruling the
newly united auradon an isle of the lost
could have taken its toll on the couple
they clashed plenty of times over this
very issue let's not forget they've
broken up more than once in the course
of the first three movies freezin to
death their breakup could be down to
their parents with the barrier down both
Hades and Maleficent are free to hang in
auradon and they are two in-laws that
would be seriously tricky to handle we
can't see either of them taking it easy
on the couple and that could rub Ben's
parents the wrong way to reason three
they might break up because one or both
of them wanted to be with someone else I
wish I had time to explain let's dive
deeper into the controversial theory who
they would date it's no secret that
Audrey's desperate to be Ben's wife her
obsession even turned her into the queen
of mean in the third movie sure she
turned good in the end but she's not
going to drop her plans for Ben that
easily
Audrey might have decided to play the
long game and sit on the sidelines until
mal and Ben's relationship imploded she
could then be the shoulder for a penny
boo to cry on that would have been a
clever move like mere Queen and moral
side-by-side
and Ben might have needed that
sympathetic shoulder when Mouse started
dating Harry hook there's obvious
chemistry between mal and Harry and he'd
be so appealing to mal when she started
to feel overwhelmed by her duties as
Queen we've seen it time and time again
that when the pressure gets to mal in
auradon she goes running back to the
Isle and Harry would be waiting for her
with his temptingly uncomplicated life
with her dad Hades rockin the guide
liner to mal might just want the
familiarity of that Rockstar pirate
world and let's not forget that dove
Cameron and Thomas Doherty are dating in
real life so it would be so fun at their
characters followed suit the situation
could even push Ben into the arms of
another pirate but more on that later
it's not so different from you when you
came to Oregon now awkward how their
friends would react it's safe to say
that Mouse crew would stick by her side
no matter what
malli DJ and Carlos have always been
tight and that's never going to change
we're your family too
we've been through a lot but things
might not be so straightforward with the
rest of the gang Jane might be torn
between loyalty to Ben and agreeing with
her BAE Carlos the same goes for Doug
and Evie could it break up these couples
- Celia dizzy and the Smee twins could
have gotten so invested in their auradon
life that they might side with Ben
rather than mal after all she did betray
them when she told Ben to permanently
close the barrier in d3 I think that we
have to close the barrier forever
although Malin uma mean nice by the end
of the third movie there are some
deep-rooted issues between these two and
the mal Harry ship might test uma and
Mouse rekindled friendship uma could be
jealous and side with Ben these two have
history even if it was down to a spell
book in descendants - just imagine if
Ben and uma struck up a relationship the
fallout from their breakup in practical
terms Mallon been breaking up could
spell disaster for both the AKS in the
vks it was thanks to this couple that
the barrier to the Isle came down so if
things got really bad between Malin Ben
it could create a divide between Oregon
and the
again people might be forced to take
sides
fights might start to break out and
let's not forget then has the beast in
him and mal has the dragon in her if
their breakup got ugly could these two
faced off as their animalistic selves in
the ultimate battle now that would be
fascinating to watch so that's a wrap on
what would happen if mal and Ben broke
up after d3 which descendants couple do
you ship the most let us know in the
comments make sure to subscribe to the
things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll catch you
next time thanks for watching